how's it going everybody this week we
got some awesome news about the low-key
TV series coming to Disney Plus if
you're not aware of what Disney Plus is
it's Disney's very own streaming service
and it's coming out in late 2019 for a
long time they didn't have a name for it
they were just calling it their Disney
streaming service but as of last week it
has been officially called Disney Plus
and there's a lot of new and exciting
things coming to it and a lot of
exclusive things come into it as well
also I'm still giving away copies of
Infinity Ward Deadpool 2 and ant-man and
the wasp on blu-ray as well as some
special edition posters if you'd like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero
so when Disney first announced their
streaming service there was talks of
doing a low-key TV series and a Scarlet
Witch TV series and there's a lot of
other TV series that are in the works
right now right now they're talking
about doing a Buckey TV series a Falcon
TV series and a Nick Fury TV series and
although these are just talks right now
it is confirmed that we are in fact
getting a Loki TV series now when we
first heard about the possibility of a
Loki TV series everybody started to
wonder well well Tom Hiddleston be Loki
and in what time will this take place in
after all the look who we know just got
strangled to death by Thanos or so we
think he is the god of mischief but last
week it has been officially confirmed
that Tom Hiddleston will in fact still
be playing Loki in this TV series Tom
Hiddleston on Instagram and Twitter on
Friday November 9th posted this photo
that says Loki more stories to tell more
mischief to make more to come this post
by Tom Hiddleston along with Disney
executives confirm the fact that Tom
Hiddleston will be playing Loki in this
eighth part TV series right now not much
is known about the show in fact it
doesn't even have an official release
date yet although we could expect it
late 2019 or later on that's when the
Disney Plus streaming service launches
but one thing you could most certainly
expect are some cameos
it's a Loki series what is Loki without
Thor without Asgard without Odin and
since Loki is being played by the same
actor Tom Hiddleston for continuity
purposes all the other actors should
remain the same as well in fact the same
day that Tom Hiddleston posted on
Twitter and Instagram
i'm jamie alexander the actress who
plays lady SIF in the MCU six minutes
after Tom Hiddleston posted posted this
picture and Mark Ruffalo himself
commented on Tom Hiddleston's post and
said Loki excited he's punny and
although these are in no way any sort of
confirmation that these actors will be
taking on their characters in this Loki
TV series it's a series about Loki and
his life
so expect to see some familiar faces
again it's going to be a eight part
series and it's going to come out
sometime after a late 2019 on Disney
Plus so what do you all think about Tom
Hiddleston getting his own series as
Loki on Disney streaming service Disney
Plus let me know what you all think
about this in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can stay up to
date on Disney streaming service Disney
Plus the Loki TV series and everything
related to a vendor's for thank you all
so much for watching
wolf wolf
[Music]
[Music]
you